durante su presentación de memor y
cuenta ante el parlamento Nicolás Maduro
pidió una vez más a Joe biden levantar
todas las sanciones que pesan contra
Venezuela las calificó de criminales
dijo que eran más de
927 que el 42% afectaba organismos
gubernamentales el 18% de la industria
petrolera y el 17% a la economía y
finanzas del país impidiendo lo demás
acceder a unos veinte mil millones de
dólares en el exterior y al oro
depositado en los bancos de Inglaterra
calificó además de ridículo y risible el
reciente apoyo que ofreció el gobierno
británico al parlamento venezolano
electo en el año 2015 de mayoría
opositora por desconocer las últimas
elecciones legislativas maduro dijo
además que las sanciones provocaron la
caída del 99% de los ingresos petroleros
en Venezuela pero que sin embargo el
producto interno bruto tuvo un
crecimiento del quince por ciento
destacó además la reducción del índice
de desempleo ocho punto nueve a siete
punto ocho por ciento sin embargo no dio
cifras sobre pobreza maduro ordenó al
gabinete presentar en las próximas
semanas un proyecto de ley para
facilitar la exportaciones en el país
una presentación de memoria y cuenta que
tuvo un inmediatas críticas por parte de
la oposición venezolana que destacó lo
que no se habló Durante este discurso de
maduro y es precisamente el tema de la
migración venezolana siete punto cinco
millones de migrantes refugiados 53% de
pobreza extrema 274 presos políticos y
un salario mínimo de menos de siete
dólares denunciaba Juan guaidó a través
de las redes sociales